decenas de cadáveres amontonados unos
simples plásticos los protegen de la
vista del público los charcos de sangre
y la tierra quemada completan la escena
aquí en la estación de trenes de grama
torsos son las consecuencias de uno de
los peores ataques contra civiles desde
que comenzó la guerra las autoridades
ucranianas acusan a rusia
la estación central de trenes de cra
motors fue alcanzada por un misil de
crucero tipo 2 kv con munición de racimo
[Música]
se han confirmado decenas de muertes en
los ataques con misiles y los heridos
fueron trasladados al hospital
grabadas todo explotó de repente y
muchas personas murieron
esta mujer acaba de enterarse de que uno
de sus familiares ha muerto
y este hombre acababa de llegar con su
abuela cuando se produjo la explosión
acabo de sacar su cuerpo sin vida del
coche había ido a comprar cigarrillos
así y la bomba estalló y vi que mi
abuela estaba muerta corrí a rescatar a
la gente que estaba más lejos
las milicias pro rusas de donges han
acusado a kiev de dicho bombardeo
tildándolo de provocación mientras que
el kremlin negó que las tropas rusas
utilicen el tipo de misiles empleados en
el ataque y acusaron a los ucranianos de
haber atacado deliberadamente la
estación de tren
aquí se debe confiar en la declaración
del ministerio de defensa que excluye el
uso de este misil por parte de las
fuerzas armadas rusas nuestras fuerzas
armadas no usan misiles de este tipo no
hubo misiones de combate en crematorio y
ninguna ha sido programada para hoy
debemos confiar en esta declaración
el alcalde de crematorio dijo que unas
4000 personas se encontraban en la
estación cuando cayeron los misiles
allí se preparaban para evacuar a
regiones más seguras mientras rusia
concentra sus tropas en el este de
ucrania